Back in June, Rick Cole was sitting in a meeting of the Pasadena Municipal Services Committee in City Hall there. That's about as dull a sentence as you could start a podcast with. But then things happen. Rick's a council member.
早在六月，里克·科尔坐在帕萨迪纳市政厅市政服务委员会的会议上。这大概是你开始播客时能用的最枯燥的一句话了。但随后事情发生了。里克是一位市议员。
And I get a text that I glance at from the police chief to the city council that says, "At 5:30, we're making a public announcement that there will be military exercises in Northeast Pasadena. They will take place at St. Luke Hospital, but do not reveal the location." This is at 5:24, six minutes before the public is to be informed.
我收到了一条短信，我瞥了一眼，是警察局长发给市议会的，上面写着：“下午5点半，我们将发布公告，称帕萨迪纳东北部将进行军事演习。演习将在圣卢克医院进行，但不要透露具体地点。”当时是下午5点24分，距离公众被告知还有六分钟。
So you saw that and you thought what?
所以你看到了那个，你当时想的是什么？
Well, I thought, that's really strange.
嗯，我想，这真的很奇怪。
It's not unprecedented there would be military exercises in a residential area. That happens in America. But still, it's strange when it's your area, with no notice at all. The meeting ends. Rick runs to another event.
在居民区进行军事演习并非史无前例。这在美国发生过。但即使这样，当这发生在你自己的辖区，而且完全没有提前通知时，还是很奇怪。会议结束了。里克跑去参加另一个活动。
Meanwhile, I had told my assistant to post on our Instagram account that this military exercise was happening and to actually identify the location. And she told me, you know, they told us very sternly not to say the location. And I said, the people deserve to know where this is happening.
与此同时，我告诉我的助理在我们的Instagram账号上发布这个军事演习正在进行的消息，并指明具体地点。她告诉我，你知道，他们非常严肃地告诉我们不要透露地点。我说，人民有权知道这在哪里发生。
And did she post the name of the hospital?
她发布了医院的名字吗？
She did.
她发布了。
Because you just figured, what are they going to do to me? I'm just going to do this?
因为你只是想，他们能拿我怎么样？我就是要这么做？
Exactly. I mean, that's the way I've lived my life, Ira.
没错。我的意思是，艾拉，这就是我一直以来的生活方式。
He's got stories. If you ever run into Rick, get him to tell you the one about how he tried to stop Christopher Columbus's great great, great great great, great great great great great, great great great great great, great great great grandson from becoming grand marshal of Pasadena's Rose Parade. But I digress. Anyway, that night in June, he heads over to this hospital, a creepy old building with broken windows and peeling paint. It's been abandoned for years. And, sure enough, sometime around 8:00 PM--
他有很多故事。如果你有机会遇到里克，一定要让他讲讲他是如何阻止克里斯托弗·哥伦布的第N代孙子成为帕萨迪纳玫瑰花车游行大礼官的故事。但我扯远了。总之，那个六月的夜晚，他前往那家医院，那是一栋破旧的建筑，窗户破碎，油漆剥落。它已经被废弃多年了。果然，在大约晚上8点左右——
These giant helicopters can be heard in the distance, getting closer and closer. Then they disgorge paratroopers clambering down ropes onto the roof of the hospital. Flashbang grenades are going off. Simulated gunfire is rattling through the neighborhood. I mean, it was jaw dropping.
远处可以听到巨大的直升机声，越来越近。然后它们放下伞兵，顺着绳子爬上医院屋顶。闪光弹爆炸了。模拟枪声在社区里回荡。我的意思是，这简直令人震惊。
This is all supposed to end by 8:30, but in fact, it wasn't over until about 2:00 AM. To Rick, this was outrageous. Why do this in a residential neighborhood with no warning, so people had no chance to prepare, maybe go elsewhere for the night, maybe give their pets tranquilizers so they don't freak out? Now people were hearing all the commotion, probably going onto their phones to figure out what was happening. And he thought he needed to jump in and explain.
这一切本应在8点半结束，但实际上直到凌晨2点左右才结束。对里克来说，这太离谱了。为什么要在没有预警的情况下在居民区这样做，让人们没有机会准备，也许晚上可以去别处，或者给宠物服用镇静剂以免它们受惊？现在人们听到了所有的骚动，可能正在用手机查看发生了什么。他认为他必须介入并解释。
Councilmember Rick Cole here in front of the former St. Luke's Hospital. As you can hear--
市议员里克·科尔在圣卢克医院旧址前。正如你所听到的——
He's in the dark. Explosions are flashing behind him, like he's some sort of suburban war correspondent.
他在黑暗中。爆炸在他身后闪烁，就像他是某种郊区战地记者一样。
Flashbangs and simulated gunfire going on-- they're going to be going on for the next half an hour, we're told.
据我们所知，闪光弹和模拟枪声还要持续半小时。
I was focused on the fact that I should tell people what's going on, because their dogs are going to bark. Their kids are going to ask questions. And they're going to wonder, why are helicopters descending on Pasadena? Why are they hearing gunfire in the neighborhood?
我专注于我应该告诉人们发生了什么，因为他们的狗会叫。他们的孩子会问问题。他们会想，为什么直升机会降落在帕萨迪纳？为什么他们在社区里听到枪声？
He'd done videos like this in the past, in the wake of the Eaton Fire last year, letting people know when it was safe to drink the water or eat vegetables from their gardens, that kind of thing.
他过去曾做过这样的视频，在去年的伊顿大火后，让人们知道什么时候可以安全饮用水或食用花园里的蔬菜，这类事情。
And this is going to go on for a while. And good luck to the people that have got to get up and go to work tomorrow morning.
而且这种情况还会持续一段时间。祝那些明天早上还要起床去上班的人好运吧。
[GUNFIRE]
[枪声]
It's funny. The weird thing about this is that it seems like you all were supposed to act like this was not a weird thing to happen.
很有趣。这件事最奇怪的地方在于，似乎你们所有人都应该表现得好像这并不是什么奇怪的事情。
That's exactly.
确实如此。
Did it make you feel sort of crazy to be told, like, oh, no, this is normal, don't sweat it?
有人告诉你“哦，不，这是正常的，别担心”，这让你觉得有点疯狂吗？
[LAUGHS] I wouldn't say crazy. It infuriated me. We owe, to the people we serve, to treat them with respect and to keep them informed about things that affect them. And this was such a egregious breach of that trust.
[笑] 我不会说疯狂。它让我非常愤怒。我们亏欠我们服务的人民，要尊重他们，并让他们了解影响他们的事情。而这完全是对这种信任的严重背叛。
Rick couldn't help but notice that nobody in the military seemed to care how everyday citizens were experiencing all this. And as a 73-year-old councilmember, he felt a duty to take what he saw as a more old-fashioned approach and reached, by the way, nearly 8 million people with his videos informing the public, succeeding more than he ever imagined.
里克不禁注意到，军方似乎没人关心普通市民是如何经历这一切的。作为一名73岁的议员，他感到有责任采取他所认为更老派的方法。顺便说一句，他的视频通过告知公众，触及了近800万人，取得了超乎他想象的成功。
Today on our program, we have stories of people who see a future arrive that feels uglier and meaner than the past. And it's not like they can turn that around. It's way too big. But in every story today, there is somebody who takes a stand and tries to clean up the mess that's around them or call attention to that mess and say no.
今天在我们的节目中，我们有关于人们目睹未来的故事，那个未来感觉比过去更丑陋、更刻薄。他们无法扭转局面。它太庞大了。但在今天的每个故事中，都有人挺身而出，试图清理他们周围的混乱，或者呼吁人们关注这种混乱并说不。
We have stories today of some very stubborn and idealistic people, from a small town in Maine to a school in Russia. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天我们有一些非常固执和理想主义者的故事，从缅因州的一个小镇到俄罗斯的一所学校。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
It's This American Life, Act One, Closing Time. Sometimes, as things change in a country because of big historic forces, doctors get put in some weird and difficult situations. That's what happened in this first act in Maine, way up north in Aroostook County. That's so far north that the Canadian border is closer than the nearest US city. The local hospital there is Houlton Regional Hospital. And last year, they announced they were going to close their labor and delivery unit, with one month's notice. Even the unit's nurse manager, Heather Quint, had no idea this was actually coming.
这里是《美国生活》，第一幕，打烊时间。有时，随着一个国家因重大的历史力量而发生变化，医生们会被置于一些奇怪且困难的境地。这就是在缅因州北部阿鲁斯图克县发生的第一幕故事。那里北到加拿大边境比最近的美国城市还要近。当地的医院是霍尔顿地区医院。去年，他们宣布将关闭分娩中心，提前一个月通知。甚至该部门的护士长希瑟·昆特也不知道这真的要发生。
It was delivered very abruptly and matter of factly, I guess. This is what's happening. Our birth rates are going down. We can't recruit. It's not, basically, a money-maker. So we're closing. There was no, I'm sorry. We hate to-- it was just very matter of factly.
我想，这个消息传达得非常突兀且公事公办。这就是正在发生的事。我们的出生率在下降。我们招不到人。基本上，它不是一个盈利部门。所以我们要关闭了。没有一句“我很抱歉”。我们很讨厌……这只是非常公事公办。
It is pretty matter-of-fact reality at this point in America, rural hospitals closing. But labor and delivery departments in particular, they've been vanishing in lots of rural areas. And when a community loses a place to have babies, in the first weeks after that happens, that's when you really see what it means in people's lives.
目前在美国，乡村医院关闭是一个非常客观的现实。但尤其是分娩部门，在许多农村地区正在消失。当一个社区失去了一个生孩子的地方，在最初几周后，你才会真正看到这对人们的生活意味着什么。
And the story in Maine unfolded just after Houlton Regional Hospital packed up its labor and delivery department, closed the doors there. As that was happening, a woman who lives in the area, named Katie Gowell, was pregnant with her fifth child. This was a low-risk pregnancy. She was planning to give birth at home, just like she'd done with her fourth child. Her family doctor, who was a midwife before she became a doctor, was going to deliver the baby. So that was the plan.
缅因州的故事就发生在霍尔顿地区医院收拾好分娩部门并关闭大门之后。就在这时，住在该地区的一位名叫凯蒂·高威尔的女性怀上了第五个孩子。这是一次低风险的怀孕。她计划像生第四个孩子那样在家分娩。她在成为医生前曾是助产士的家庭医生将为她接生。这就是计划。
29 days after Houlton closed its labor and delivery department, Katie Gowell went into labor at home. Reporter Elaine Appleton Grant has the story of what happened next. Quick heads up before we start-- some of us here on staff found ourselves thinking about the TV show The Pitt as we were making this story, because there's no way to explain what happened without diving into some very vivid medical details during childbirth. I just want to say, if that's not for you, please know that is part of this story. Here's Elaine Appleton Grant.
霍尔顿关闭分娩部门29天后，凯蒂·高威尔在家中开始分娩。记者伊莱恩·阿普尔顿·格兰特讲述了接下来的故事。在开始之前先提醒一下——我们在制作这个故事时，我们团队中的一些人想到了电视节目《急诊室的故事》，因为如果不深入探讨分娩过程中一些非常生动的医疗细节，就无法解释发生了什么。我只想说，如果这不适合你，请知道这是故事的一部分。这里是伊莱恩·阿普尔顿·格兰特。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
I'm like, well, Mom, maybe I shouldn't have called them already, because it was sort of-- I kind of went like a standstill for a while.
我说，嗯，妈妈，也许我不应该已经给他们打电话了，因为有一段时间它有点停滞了。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
But all of a sudden, it was like someone poked me awake. And I sat bolt upright. And I said, what did Katie say? And Katie was down the hallway in the bathroom at that point. So I went down there, and I said, did you say something? And she said, yeah. I said, my water broke.
但突然之间，就像有人把我戳醒了。我坐得笔直。我说，凯蒂说了什么？那时候凯蒂在走廊尽头的浴室里。所以我走过去，我说，你说了什么吗？她说，是的。我说，我的羊水破了。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
And then I just sat there for a few minutes. And so then I'm like, well, I'm going to get up now. And then I went to wipe, and I felt something.
然后我就坐在那里几分钟。然后我说，好吧，我现在要起床了。然后我去擦拭时，感觉到了一些东西。
And she said, what's that? And I looked down in the toilet, and there was probably 8 inches of cord hanging out, not quite touching the toilet water, but close. So I was like, immediately, this is very bad. This is a prolapsed cord, which rarely happens. I just said, it looks like the cord. We need to check you out. And let's get in the bed.
她说，那是什么？我低头看马桶，大概有8英寸长的脐带垂出来，没有完全触碰到马桶水，但很接近。我立刻觉得，这非常糟糕。这是一个脐带脱垂，很少发生。我只是说，看起来是脐带。我们需要检查一下。让我们上床。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
And we got her on the bed. And I was checking to see if she's completely dilated, ready to push the baby out. I thought, it's her fifth baby. I thought, if we could give one push and finish this, I'll do that. But that wasn't the case. She was probably about 6 centimeters.
我们让她躺在床上。我正在检查她是否完全扩张，准备把孩子生出来。我想，这是她的第五个孩子。我想，如果我们能用力推一下并完成它，我会这么做。但事实并非如此。她大概开了6厘米。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
I was terrified, because I didn't want the baby to die.
我吓坏了，因为我不想让孩子死。
(INTERVIEWER) ELAINE APPLETON
（采访者）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
I turned around. And my nurse has beautiful big, blue eyes. And they always comfort me in the middle of anything. And I turned around, and I looked in her eyes. And I said, call 911. And her eyes went two sizes bigger because she's actually never heard me say that in working with her 12 years. Yeah.
我转过身。我的护士有一双漂亮的大蓝眼睛。在任何情况下，它们总是能安慰我。我转过身，看着她的眼睛。我说，打911。她的眼睛瞪大了两倍，因为在她和我共事12年里，从来没听过我说这句话。是的。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
I started to coach her that the life of the baby is at stake, and you're going to have to go through quite a bit if we're going to hope to save your child.
我开始指导她，孩子的生命危在旦夕，如果你想救你的孩子，你必须经历很多痛苦。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
Because me, being in the moment, I don't remember every detail, where she would remember every detail. And I trust her with telling my story. I trust her completely with everything.
因为我当时身处其中，我不记得每一个细节，而她记得每一个细节。我信任她讲述我的故事。我完全信任她处理一切。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
I chose what I thought was the best course of action, which-- I gently replaced it into the vagina. Is that OK to say on tape? OK, gently replaced it inside so that the warmth of her body would keep the cord warm, because I knew we're in Maine, and although it was June, it wasn't that warm.
我选择了我认为最好的行动方案，那就是——我轻轻地把它放回阴道里。在录音带上说这个没问题吧？好的，轻轻地放进去，这样她身体的温度可以保持脐带温暖，因为我知道我们在缅因州，虽然是六月，但并不那么暖和。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
I shifted myself and climbed onto the bed between her legs, crouching, sort of on all fours, kneeling, crouching down.
我挪动了一下，爬上床，双腿分开，蹲着，四肢着地，跪着，蹲伏下来。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
I was internally inside the patient, pushing upward toward her head as, basically, hard as I could, using two fingers to push up, the rest of my fingers to lightly be touching the cord to keep track of the heart tones at all times. Because if they slowed down, I knew something's pinching. If they slowed down, I also knew I needed to push up higher and get the head up higher.
我在患者体内，尽量向上朝着她的头推，基本上是用尽全力，用两根手指推，其余手指轻轻触碰脐带，时刻追踪心音。因为如果它们慢下来，我就知道有什么东西在挤压。如果它们慢下来，我也知道我需要推得更高，把头顶得更高。
(INTERVIEWER) ELAINE APPLETON
（采访者）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
Probably up to my wrist, starting forearm. Meanwhile, Katie's own body wants to push the baby out, right? Contractions push down. So to have my hand, that's painful for her. And I knew it was painful. And I told her, I'm very sorry, but I can't care about your pain. It's a very weird pain. It's a deep pain. Anyone who's had a cervical biopsy, an endometrial biopsy, an IUD put in-- I think it's a pain no one can describe. And then this is times a whole lot more, because there's a baby in there too, and now someone's hand as well.
大概到我的手腕，开始到前臂。与此同时，凯蒂的身体想要把孩子推出来，对吧？宫缩向下推。所以我的手在里面，这让她很痛苦。我知道这很痛苦。我告诉她，我非常抱歉，但我现在无法顾及你的疼痛。这是一种非常奇怪的疼痛。这是一种深层的疼痛。任何做过宫颈活检、子宫内膜活检、放过节育环的人——我想这是一种无法描述的痛。而这还要严重得多，因为里面还有一个婴儿，现在还有一只手。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
I said, no, we're not. And they said, well, that's what they're saying. I said, I don't care what they're saying. We are not doing that. You tell them a doctor's on site.
我说，不，我们不去。他们说，嗯，这就是他们说的。我说，我不在乎他们怎么说。我们不会那样做。你告诉他们有医生在现场。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
And I said, you call Houlton Regional. You're telling them we're coming. And I mean, we're coming.
我说，你打给霍尔顿地区医院。你告诉他们我们要去了。我的意思是，我们要去了。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
I said, Sasha, then get a chainsaw and cut the wall down.
我说，萨沙，那就拿把电锯把墙锯开。
(INTERVIEWER) ELAINE APPLETON
（采访者）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
He was ready to go get a chainsaw and cut the wall down because they knew I wasn't moving, and I wasn't allowing her to get up. I didn't care if it was EMS and their truck. I was not giving over my place of authority, because I did not see that they had adequate knowledge or understanding of the situation.
他准备去拿电锯把墙锯开，因为他们知道我不会动，我也不会让她起来。我不在乎那是急救人员还是他们的车。我不会交出我的指挥权，因为我不认为他们对情况有足够的了解或理解。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
We always count to three, and then we all pull together, like a bunch of he-men. So he's like, who's going to count? And how are we going to do this? Are you going to count? Who's going to count? They just kept on like that. And I looked at my nurse, and I said, you count. So she took over. Like, she heard me say that, and that was it. And I hate to get real loud on this mic, but she proceeded to just roar. We're going to count. 1, 2, 3! And honestly, I think she almost single-handedly pulled me, Katie over to the gurney, with them helping some.
我们总是数到三，然后像一群大汉一样一起用力。所以他说，谁来数？我们怎么做？你来数？谁来数？他们就这样一直磨蹭。我看着我的护士，我说，你来数。所以她接手了。她听到我这么说，就是这样。我不想在这个麦克风前大喊大叫，但她开始咆哮。我们要数了。1，2，3！老实说，我认为她几乎是单枪匹马地把我和凯蒂拉到了担架上，他们也帮了一些忙。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
It's a very bumpy road. These are the back roads of the county, right? So potholes, bumps, very curvy. At times, I thought I was going to fall off the gurney. And the paramedic would grab the waistband on the back of my skirt and hold me so I would hold steady. And I needed to hold steady. My hand had to hold steady.
路非常颠簸。这是县里的乡间小路，对吧？所以有坑洼、颠簸，非常弯曲。有时，我觉得我要从担架上掉下来了。医护人员会抓住我裙子后面的腰带稳住我，这样我就能保持平稳。我需要保持平稳。我的手必须保持平稳。
And her leg, at one point, slipped off the gurney and sort of fell down. And so I grabbed her leg and pulled it back up, and I was holding her leg on the gurney with me. So it was a tight squeeze. I was beginning to feel exhausted. I myself don't have the best back, and this was a very awkward position. And your legs are all curled up under you. So you're in an intense kneeling-- sitting on your legs, squatting. So my legs are falling asleep. My hand is starting to fall asleep from the angle that I'm at.
有一次她的腿从担架上滑了下来，垂了下去。所以我抓住她的腿拉了回来，我把她的腿和我在担架上一起托住。这地方很挤。我开始感到精疲力竭。我自己的背也不好，这是一个非常尴尬的姿势。你的腿都蜷在身下。所以你处于一种强烈的跪姿——跪在你的腿上，蹲着。所以我的腿开始麻了。我的手因为角度问题也开始麻了。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
But my hand would periodically feel like it was completely numb. And I would worry, like, am I going to be pinching this cord? And then it would wake up again intermittently. But it was painful, like when your hand falls asleep and it's very painful. It was becoming physically very painful to continue.
但我的手会时不时感觉完全麻木。我会担心，我会不会在掐断这根脐带？然后它会间歇性地醒过来。但这很痛苦，就像手麻了之后那种非常痛苦的感觉。继续这样做在身体上变得非常痛苦。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
LifeFlight still headed to Houlton Regional?
“生命飞行”救援队还在赶往霍尔顿地区吗？
Correct.
没错。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
Yeah. They just started spooling up. I'm looking out my window at them. So yeah. That's our plan.
是啊。他们刚刚开始加速。我从窗户看着他们。所以是的。那是我们的计划。
They are just now leaving the scene, headed to the hospital.
他们现在正离开现场，赶往医院。
I did not agree with that plan at all, because I knew that I could not take another however many minutes it would take to get into LifeFlight, and them to fuel up, and then to stay like that till a C-section can be done at Eastern Maine Hospital in Bangor. There's just no way.
我完全不同意那个计划，因为我知道我无法再忍受飞往“生命飞行”救援队、他们加油、然后在班戈的东缅因医院进行剖腹产所需的时间。根本不可能。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
I think they woke me up from sleep. So it was one of those, like, ring, ring, phone call. What's going on? OK. I'll be there in five minutes.
我想他们把我从睡梦中叫醒了。所以那是那种叮铃铃的电话。发生什么事了？好的。我五分钟内赶到。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
But I'm here. At that point, I'm like, no, we'll have the baby here. And let's go ahead and call in the OR team, and we should deliver her here. We still have that capability. And everyone at that point was like, oh, yeah, we can do that.
但我在这里。那时我想，不，我们就在这里生孩子。让我们继续叫手术室团队，我们应该在这里进行分娩。我们仍然有这种能力。那时每个人都说，哦，是的，我们可以那样做。
(INTERVIEWER) ELAINE APPLETON
（采访者）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
Yeah. They didn't even really think about the fact they still had that capability. But at that transition time, they did.
是的。他们甚至没怎么想过他们还有这种能力。但在那个过渡时间，他们想到了。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
And so we pulled up at the ambulance entrance, and the obstetrician came outside to meet us, which I was so glad for, and started taking the history from me while we were unloading.
所以我们停在救护车入口处，产科医生出来迎接我们，我对此感到非常高兴，我们在卸下担架时，她开始从我这里获取病史。
And I was like, hi, I'm Dr. Tschirhart. I'm an OB/GYN. I'm the one on call today. Recommendation is emergency C-section, if it's OK with you. And we're going to roll you right into the operating room and deliver the baby. Dr. Fuchs also was giving me kind of a sign-out about what was happening with her, what her background was, and that she could still feel the cord pulse.
我说，嗨，我是奇尔哈特医生。我是妇产科医生。今天我是值班医生。建议是紧急剖腹产，如果你同意的话。我们会直接把你推进手术室，把孩子生出来。福克斯医生也给了我一些关于她情况的交代，她的背景是什么，以及她还能感觉到脐带搏动。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
So we basically put the surgical drapes over the top of Dr. Fuchs, threw the Betadine sterilizing fluid on Katie.
所以我们基本上把手术铺巾盖在福克斯医生的头顶，把聚维酮碘消毒液倒在凯蒂身上。
They opened a bottle of iodine and dumped it over her belly, over my top of my arm, my forearm that was near her. So my cheek is laying on Katie's thigh. I have my head sideways, trying to breathe in a little air pocket in this drape. It's a very awkward position, to say the least, for her and me.
他们打开一瓶碘酒，倒在她的肚子上，倒在我靠近她手臂的一侧。所以我的脸贴在凯蒂的大腿上。我侧着头，试图在这个铺巾里呼吸一点空气。至少可以说，对她和我来说，这是一个非常尴尬的姿势。
We have surgical equipment and tubing and electrocautery and suction kind of sitting on top of Dr. Fuchs, because she's right there between Katie's legs.
我们有手术设备、管道、电灼器和吸引器，基本上都堆在福克斯医生身上，因为她就在凯蒂的双腿之间。
I can feel they are putting their tools on my back.
我能感觉到他们把工具放在我的背上。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
And nurses sort of scurried about, looking for a Doppler. They either couldn't find one or they didn't have one available, but they had no Doppler anyway. And so I told her, it's OK, because I can feel the heartbeat. And so it had been 120s. But then at one point, while they were still prepping, it went down to, like, 90. And so I called that out to her. I said, so we're down to 90. You all better hurry.
护士们四处乱跑，寻找多普勒仪。他们要么找不到，要么没有，但他们本来就没有多普勒仪。所以我告诉她，没关系，因为我可以感觉到心跳。心跳一度是120多次。但后来在他们准备时，降到了90。所以我喊了出来。我说，现在降到90了。你们最好快点。
(INTERVIEWER) ELAINE APPLETON
（采访者）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
A normal fetal heart rate is 120 to 160. And so we allow a little bit outside that range, but 90 is definitely getting in trouble. It's often the signal that there's an impending disaster. My fear was the next beat was going to be 60 and the next beat nothing. And then I did my usual, which-- I pushed a little harder on the head, tried a little harder to protect the cord, and I felt the heart rate go back up to the 120s. So then I called out again to reassure them, we're back up to the 120. You're OK. We're doing all right.
正常胎心率是120到160。所以我们允许一点点超出这个范围，但90绝对是出问题了。这通常是灾难即将发生的信号。我担心下一次心跳是60，再下一次就没了。然后我做了我平时的动作——我用力压了一下头，试图更努力地保护脐带，我感觉到心率又回到了120多次。所以我又喊出来安慰他们，我们回到了120。你们没事。我们做得很好。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
As soon as she went to sleep, I made the incision, got down to her uterus.
她一睡着，我就切开了切口，进入了她的子宫。
I could feel them start to cut the skin and the muscle layers to enter the abdomen. And I thought, oh, dear, my fingers are awfully high up there. What if they cut my fingers? I better pull back a little bit at just the right moment, but not too soon to lose the heartbeat. So I withdrew a little bit. And then I could sort of feel them, that they were in the uterus.
我能感觉到他们开始切开皮肤和肌肉层进入腹部。我想，噢天哪，我的手指在那里太高了。如果他们切到我的手怎么办？我最好在恰当的时候稍微退后一点，但又不能太早，以免失去心跳。所以我撤回了一点。然后我能感觉到他们进入了子宫。
And my hand reached down to pull the baby's head out, and our hands touched. So my hand touched Dr. Fuchs's hand as I was lifting the baby's head out of the incision.
我的手伸下去把婴儿的头拉出来，我们的手碰到了。所以我在把孩子头拉出切口时，我的手碰到了福克斯医生的手。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
I could see her off to my left, when she was getting worked on. And then when I was in the recovery room, she was still getting worked on, because then that's when they put her in their incubator type thing. I still didn't get to hold her.
她在接受处理时，我能在左边看到她。然后在我在恢复室时，她还在接受处理，因为那是他们把她放进保温箱之类的时候。我还是没能抱她。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
I cried. I cried. I didn't know at that time-- I didn't know how she was. I didn't get to see her. I didn't get to know anything. And then I just saw them wheel her away. It's just a-- I don't know how to describe-- it's a very hard thing, especially seeing her leave. I don't know. It's just-- it was hard, very hard.
我哭了。我哭了。那时我不知道——我不知道她怎么样。我没能见到她。我什么都不知道。然后我就看着他们把她推走。那只是一个——我不知道该怎么形容——这真是太难了，尤其是看着她离开。我不知道。那只是——这很艰难，非常艰难。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
I wanted to be like-- when they closed it down, I wanted to be like, OK, this is what you guys want? This is what you're going to get. But the nurse in me, the person in me-- that's my patient. Hell, yes, I'm going to be there. I threw on my clothes, and I was there. And I went to Bangor with her. And I sat, and I held her hand, and I talked to her the entire time. So, no. Oh. When I got the call, I wanted to be like, figure it out, but not when my patients are involved. I'm like, yep, I'll be right down.
当他们关闭部门时，我当时想说，好吧，这是你们想要的吗？这就是你们将得到的。但作为一名护士，作为一个普通人——那是我的病人。地狱啊，是的，我会在那里。我穿上衣服，我去了。我和她一起去了班戈。我坐在那里，握着她的手，全程一直和她说话。所以，不。哦。当我接到电话时，我本来想说，你们自己搞定吧，但当涉及到我的病人时，我就不会这样。我说，是的，我马上下来。
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
（主持人）伊莱恩·阿普尔顿
Elaine Appleton Grant. That story was produced by Lilly Sullivan and edited by Phia Bennin. Elaine originally learned about this story from reporting by Emily Hedegard and Stephanie McFeeters of The Maine Monitor. Coming up, raise your hand if you know what Труд -- дело чести means. That's in a minute, comrades, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
伊莱恩·阿普尔顿·格兰特。那个故事由莉莉·沙利文制作，菲娅·贝宁编辑。伊莱恩最初是从《缅因州观察报》的艾米丽·赫德加德和斯蒂芬妮·麦克菲特斯的报道中了解到这个故事的。接下来，如果你知道“Труд -- дело чести”意味着什么，请举手。稍后回来，同志们，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "I Couldn't Help but Notice," we have stories where people see a new future arrive, one that is not quite as pleasant as the past. And they can't help themselves. They take action, in some way or another, in their own little corner of the world. We've arrived at act two of our program. Act Two, Conversations About Important Things.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“我忍不住注意到”，我们有一些故事，人们看到了一个新未来的到来，这个未来不像过去那么令人愉快。他们情不自禁。他们以这样或那样的方式，在自己世界的小角落里采取行动。我们现在进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，关于重要事情的谈话。
So the documentary that won this year's Academy Award is called Mr. Nobody Against Putin. It was co-directed by a Russian guy and an American, Pasha Talankin and David Borenstein. And it's about the propaganda campaign that was rolled out in Russia after Russia invaded Ukraine in 2022 and the shock of that propaganda push, for one person in particular. If you haven't seen the film, it is really worth seeing. And one of the people on staff here at This American Life, Valerie Kipnis, has watched it four times. She'll tell you why. Here's Val.
今年获得奥斯卡金像奖的纪录片名叫《无名者对抗普京》。它由一位俄罗斯人和一位美国人共同执导，帕夏·塔兰金和大卫·博伦斯坦。它是关于2022年俄罗斯入侵乌克兰后在俄罗斯展开的宣传运动，以及对其中一个人来说，这种宣传冲击带来的震惊。如果你没看过这部电影，它真的很值得一看。而在《美国生活》工作的一位工作人员瓦莱丽·基普尼斯已经看了四遍了。她会告诉你原因。这里是瓦尔。
Here are some scenes from my family growing up. Someone, let's say my mom, would say this to me. Glory to labor! She'd say it in Russian. Then she'd hand me a broom. Or she'd say, Труд -- дело чести. Labor is a matter of honor. She used to say that on Sunday morning when she woke me up for chores.
这是我小时候家里的一些场景。有人，比如说我妈妈，会对我这么说。劳动光荣！她会用俄语说。然后她会递给我一把扫帚。或者她会说，“Труд -- дело чести”。劳动是一种荣誉。她以前在周日早上叫我起床做家务时常这么说。
These are all propaganda slogans from her upbringing in the Soviet Union. She and my dad both grew up there. My dad would say things like this too. So did my grandmothers. They both live with us. And these lines always got a laugh from each other. Like, my mom would say, Партия -- наш рулевой!. The party is our helmsman. And my grandmother, Bella, would laugh and say, last time I saw that one was on the wall of an auditorium.
这些都是她在苏联成长过程中的宣传口号。她和我爸爸都是在那里长大的。我爸爸也会说这样的话。我的祖母们也是。她们俩都和我们住在一起。而这些台词总是让彼此发笑。比如，我妈妈会说，“Партия -- наш рулевой!”。党是我们的舵手。而我的祖母贝拉会笑笑说，我上次看到这个是在礼堂的墙上。
Unlike them, I grew up here, which meant I was always behind, always playing catch-up in a household full of inside jokes, always trying to see into this world they had in their heads. I was obsessed with it. So I'd ask the same questions over and over again. And they would answer my questions patiently, kindly, on long car rides, on the subway to school, on our walks near the BQE.
和她们不同，我是在这里长大的，这意味着我总是落后，总是在一个充满内部笑话的家庭里追赶，总是试图看清她们脑子里的世界。我对此着迷。所以我一遍又一遍地问同样的问题。她们会在漫长的车程里、在去学校的地铁上、在我们靠近BQE的人行道上，耐心地、亲切地回答我的问题。
But I kept going. I wanted to understand what it actually felt like to live surrounded by banners and slogans. My grandmother would shrug and say что было, то было. It just was what it was. It didn't feel special to us. We didn't know another version of life. And then she'd call me by my family nickname, почемучка, which means, roughly, "kid who drives us crazy by asking why all the time."
但我一直追问。我想了解生活在被横幅和口号包围的环境中到底是什么感觉。我的祖母会耸耸肩说“что было, то было”。过去的就是过去了。这对我们来说并不觉得特别。我们不知道另一种生活。然后她会用我的小名“почемучка”称呼我，这大致意思就是“总是问为什么把我们逼疯的孩子”。
Being a почемучка and all, it's only natural that I watched this new documentary four times-- three times before it won the Oscar, just saying. And the thing I couldn't get enough of was that here was a movie that answered some of the questions I'd been asking for so long. The documentary starts less than a month after Russia invaded Ukraine, the beginning of the full-scale invasion.
作为一个“为什么宝宝”，我看了四遍这部新纪录片是很自然的——在它获得奥斯卡之前看了三遍，我只是提一下。我怎么看都不够的原因是，这部电影回答了我长期以来一直问的一些问题。这部纪录片开始于俄罗斯入侵乌克兰不到一个月后，即全面入侵的开始。
And it focuses on one school in one town in Russia as the Ministry of Education rolls out a massive, nationwide propaganda campaign, a new, quote, "patriotic curriculum," which would include new lesson plans for teachers, nationalistic poem recitations for students, mandatory school-wide salutes to the flag, and mandatory lessons called Разговоры о важном. Conversations about Important Things, where teachers are asked to talk about stuff like the importance of war songs or the heroism of Russian fighters.
它聚焦于俄罗斯一个城镇的一所学校，当时教育部推出了大规模的、全国性的宣传运动，一项新的、引用，“爱国课程”，其中包括教师的新教案、学生朗诵民族主义诗歌、强制全校向旗帜致敬，以及名为“关于重要事情的谈话”的强制课程。关于重要事情的谈话，教师被要求谈论战争歌曲的重要性或俄罗斯战士的英雄主义。
Also, a single approved set of history textbooks, written by two people closely affiliated with the Kremlin. High-schoolers would start paramilitary training in gym class. And in the school that's in the documentary, one teacher captures how this all plays out, Pasha Talankin. And I called him up.
此外，还有一套经过批准的历史教科书，由两名与克里姆林宫关系密切的人编写。高中生将在体育课上开始准军事训练。而在纪录片里的那所学校，一位老师帕夏·塔兰金捕捉到了这一切是如何发生的。我打电话给了他。
Here was a person who made a whole film about what it felt like to see slogans in the auditorium, different slogans than the ones my parents and grandparents grew up with-- a very different time-- but with an undeniable similarity. Both then and now, the state had a tight grip on its own people. And here was Pasha, who wasn't just seeing what was happening around him. He wanted the whole world to see what he was seeing.
他是一个拍了一整部关于在礼堂看到标语是什么感觉的电影的人，标语和我父母祖辈长大的标语不同——这是一个非常不同的时代——但有着不可否认的相似之处。无论过去还是现在，国家对人民都有严格的控制。而在这里的帕夏，他不仅看到了周围发生的事情。他希望全世界看到他所看到的。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
This is Pasha. He's got a round, wide-eyed baby face, big glasses. He's an impish kind of person who talks through a smile, like he's in on some joke you don't know about. The school in the film is actually the same school he once attended. And he loves the school, loves his students, loves his grumpy mom. She's the school librarian. And when the film begins, he's the school's event coordinator and videographer. He films the piano recitals, graduations, performances.
这是帕夏。他有一张圆圆的、睁大眼睛的婴儿脸，戴着大眼镜。他是一个顽皮的人，说话时带着微笑，就像他知道什么你不知道的笑话一样。电影里的学校其实就是他曾经就读的那所学校。他热爱学校，热爱学生，热爱他那脾气暴躁的妈妈。她是学校图书管理员。当电影开始时，他是学校的活动协调员和摄像师。他拍摄钢琴独奏会、毕业典礼、表演。
And under the brand-new patriotic curriculum at Pasha's school, Pasha was told he now had a brand-new role. He would be filming teachers and students performing the new lessons. He'd be filming the new flag salutes and paramilitary trainings. And he would be sending all of that footage to the government as proof of compliance. I wanted to know what he thought of his new role as he was doing it, how it actually felt. He answered by telling me a story that never made it into the film.
而在帕夏学校全新的爱国课程下，帕夏被告知他现在有了全新的角色。他将拍摄教师和学生进行新课程的表演。他将拍摄新的旗帜致敬仪式和准军事训练。他将把所有这些片段发送给政府作为合规证明。我想知道他在做这些时是怎么想的，实际感觉如何。他通过给我讲一个从未进入电影的故事回答了我。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
What was I thinking about when I filmed this? I mean, at first, I was just-- how do you say this in Russia? I started sweating under my visor. I just lost my mind about what was happening. I just totally freaked out.
我拍这个的时候在想什么？我的意思是，起初，我只是——你在俄罗斯怎么说这个？我开始在面罩下出汗。我简直疯了，不知道发生了什么。我完全吓坏了。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
When I was going to film computer class-- it didn't end up in the final cut-- I asked myself a question.
当我准备去拍计算机课时——它没有出现在最终剪辑中——我问了自己一个问题。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
Who is that idiot who was going to be watching all this shit? Who is he? Who is that moron? I mean, it should be some sort of paid job, sitting and watching all this shit. They should pay you some money for that, at least a little bit. Anyway, I did this one little bit of trickery, where I left in only the beginning of the class, where the teacher says, hello, kids, and the end, where they say, OK, class is over. But the shot itself went the whole time of the class, 45 minutes. So in the middle, there was just a black screen, as if something had gone wrong with my camera.
那个要看这些烂东西的白痴是谁？他是谁？那个笨蛋是谁？我的意思是，这应该是一种付费工作，坐着看这些垃圾。他们至少应该为此付点钱。总之，我耍了个小聪明，只保留了课堂的开头，老师说，孩子们好，以及结尾，他们说，好的，下课了。但拍摄本身持续了整节课，45分钟。所以中间只有黑屏，好像我的摄像机出了问题一样。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
And I sent the video in. And I sat there waiting as they looked over the footage. And I kept waiting for them to say, we can't see it. Something went wrong. It's just a black screen. And they didn't give me a single note. And I thought--
然后我把视频发了过去。我坐在那里等着，他们检查了片段。我一直等着他们说，我们看不到。出了问题。只是个黑屏。他们没给我任何反馈。我想——
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
--holy shit. I'm here not to actually record, but to surveil the teachers. Watch out. We're watching you. We have a camera. Here it is, recording you. And in that moment, I thought, I'm being used.
——天哪。我在这里不是为了记录，而是为了监视老师。小心。我们在看着你。我们有摄像机。在这里，记录着你们。在那一刻，我想，我正在被利用。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
I'm being used.
我正在被利用。
He figured, yeah, OK, they were using him. But he was simultaneously and obsessively filming the changes at his school for his own purposes. And the footage that Pasha captured was really eye-opening for me. It answered so many of the questions I'd badgered my family with over the years.
他想，是的，好吧，他们正在利用他。但他同时又强迫症般地为了自己的目的拍摄学校的变化。而帕夏捕捉到的镜头真的让我大开眼界。它回答了我在过去几年里一直缠着家人问的许多问题。
Because the propaganda, as it rolls out, is sort of the opposite of what I'd always imagined it would be, you know, the classic images of state control-- the seamless, crisp obedience, massive signs, arms being raised in unison, echoey speeches delivered to neat rows of thousands of people. Pasha shows scenes that are so intimate and small and messy, a teacher stumbling over new words she's now required to say, denazification, demilitarization.
因为宣传，随着它的展开，和我一直想象的某种相反，你知道，国家控制的经典形象——无缝、干脆的服从，巨大的标语，手臂整齐地抬起，在成千上万人的整齐队列中发表回响的演讲。帕夏展示的场景是如此私密、微小且混乱，一位老师在结结巴巴地念她现在被要求说的那些新词，去纳粹化，去军事化。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
He films teenagers, bored out of their minds, staring blindly into space as another teacher tells them--
他拍下青少年们，无聊透顶，茫然地盯着空间，另一位老师告诉他们——
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
If you were born in this country and you don't believe we're doing the right thing, then leave. Go to the country that you think is better. Pasha films young kids with these tiny red berets, chanting new slogans in an assembly.
如果你出生在这个国家，你不相信我们正在做正确的事，那就离开。去你认为更好的国家。帕夏拍下了戴着这些红色小贝雷帽的年轻孩子，在集会上高呼新口号。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
They're excited, but looking at each other, like, right? We're saying the right thing? The school days in the film look kind of normal in so many ways, despite all the changes. Kids still horse around and tease each other. There are still piano recitals. It's still just school. But Pasha was like the kid in the Emperor's New Clothes. Every change stood out to him. And he couldn't stop talking about it. His own mother was like, of course these things are happening. They've always been this way. Shut up. And he argued with her.
他们很兴奋，但看着对方，就像，对吗？我们说的是对的吗？电影里的上学日子在许多方面看起来很正常，尽管有所有的变化。孩子们仍然打闹、互相取笑。仍然有钢琴独奏会。这仍然只是上学。但帕夏就像《皇帝的新衣》里的那个孩子。每一个变化在他眼中都显得突出。他无法停止谈论它。他自己的妈妈说，这些事情当然会发生。它们一直都是这样。闭嘴。而他和她争论。
He lived in a sort of continuous state of shock about the war, about the propaganda. And he told me that when the patriotic curriculum started, he kept sort of waiting for the people around him to freak out as much as he was about what they were being asked to do. But most people just went along with it, adapted, or chose to stay quiet. I wondered why he didn't do that. Then, when I talked to him, I got it.
他处于一种持续的战争冲击状态，关于宣传。他告诉我，当爱国课程开始时，他一直等着周围的人像他一样对他们被要求做的事情感到震惊。但大多数人只是随波逐流，适应，或选择保持沉默。我好奇为什么他不那样做。然后，当我与他交谈时，我明白了。
For starters, Pasha and I are almost the same age, in our 30s. And part of why he's so stunned by what's happening is because of the era he grew up in. It was right after the Soviet Union fell apart, but before Vladimir Putin really started consolidating power. So Pasha was raised in this short window of time when students weren't flooded with slogans and propaganda in the schools, when schools were left mostly untouched by the state apparatus, because the state apparatus had fallen apart.
首先，帕夏和我年纪差不多，都在30多岁。他之所以对正在发生的事情感到如此震惊，部分原因是他成长的时代。那是在苏联解体之后，但在普京真正开始巩固权力之前。所以帕夏是在一个短暂的时间窗口里长大的，那时学生们没有被学校里的口号和宣传所淹没，那时学校大部分没有受到国家机器的干扰，因为国家机器已经解体了。
And so what Pasha was seeing was something my parents and grandparents never got to see-- the beginning of a propaganda push in the schools, which meant he understood what his school was losing when it adopted these changes. And he knew what he was personally losing as nationalism became more and more strictly enforced.
所以帕夏所看到的，是我父母和祖辈从未见过的——学校里宣传攻势的开始，这意味着他明白当他的学校采用这些变化时正在失去什么。他知道当民族主义变得越来越严格执行时，他个人失去了什么。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
Over and over again in the film, he addresses people in his life in the camera directly. Like, can you believe this? Why is this happening? Potchemy.
在电影中，他一次又一次地直接对着摄像机对着他生活中的人说话。比如，你相信吗？为什么会发生这种情况？为什么？
He told me that off camera, he had many more exchanges like that, especially with the other teachers.
他告诉我，在镜头外，他有更多那样的交流，特别是和其他老师。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
The teachers came to me. They said, Pasha, we don't like all this. And then they come into class and started to say what the Ministry of Education had sent over to them.
老师们来找我。他们说，帕夏，我们不喜欢这一切。然后他们走进教室，开始说教育部发给他们的那些话。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
The teachers are hostages of this system too.
老师们也是这个系统的受害者。
Pasha also saw himself as a hostage. Before the war and the new curriculum, Pasha was the teacher with the Pussy Riot poster on his wall, the cool guy, the weirdo whose office all the theater kids hung out in, the teacher who had different politics than what was on TV every night.
帕夏也把自己视为受害者。在战争和新课程之前，帕夏是墙上挂着Pussy Riot海报的老师，酷哥，那个所有戏剧孩子都在他办公室里闲逛的怪胎，那个政见与每晚电视上播放的内容不同的老师。
And for a while, even after the war was underway, he was able to continue being that guy. He wore blue and yellow paperclips on his clothing as symbols of support for Ukraine. He hung an image of an anti-war flag in his office, flipped a Russian flag outside the school upside down. One time, he even played Lady Gaga singing "The Star-Spangled Banner" during a flag assembly instead of the Russian national anthem.
有一段时间，即使在战争正在进行时，他仍然能够保持那个样子。他在衣服上戴着蓝黄色回形针作为支持乌克兰的象征。他在办公室挂了一张反战旗帜的图片，把学校外面的俄罗斯国旗倒挂。有一次，他甚至在国旗集会上播放了Lady Gaga唱的《星条旗永不落》，而不是俄罗斯国歌。
In the movie, he does things that I could not believe he was getting away with. In a country that was introducing laws to criminalize things, like even saying that the war was, in fact, a war, how on Earth could he just do these things and not get in trouble?
在电影里，他做的事情让我无法相信他居然能逃脱惩罚。在一个引入法律将诸如承认战争实际上是一场战争之类的行为定为犯罪的国家，他怎么可能就这样做而不惹上麻烦？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
People sort of saw me as--
人们有点看我像——
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
--a jester, a holy fool. There he goes, walking around, being foolish.
——一个小丑，一个神圣的傻瓜。你看那儿，到处走动，耍宝。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
In Russia, there is this historical tradition that the jester, the holy fool, could speak out, even to the tzar. The lowest level of society, the most seemingly worthless people, they could say exactly what they thought, tell anyone right to their face.
在俄罗斯，有这样一种历史传统，小丑、神圣的傻瓜，即使是对沙皇也可以直言不讳。社会最底层，看起来最无用的人，他们可以确切地说出自己的想法，对着任何人的脸说出来。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
But that didn't mean the tzars would just ignore him forever. When I talked to Pasha about how his constant provoking was playing out in real life, he told me that behind the scenes of making the film, he could feel his status changing from holy fool to persona non grata. This isn't in the film, but at some point, at Pasha's school, compliance started being supervised in person via a new, quote, "advisor on student affairs." And this advisor took a special interest in Pasha.
但这并不意味着沙皇会永远忽视他。当我与帕夏谈论他不断挑衅在现实生活中是如何上演时，他告诉我，在制作电影的幕后，他能感觉到自己的地位从神圣的傻瓜变成了不受欢迎的人。电影里没提，但在帕夏学校的某个时刻，合规开始通过一名新的、引用，“学生事务顾问”进行现场监督。而这位顾问对帕夏特别感兴趣。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
This advisor was supposed to monitor student activity on social media, establish contact with them, basically sniff everything out. And so one day, this advisor came to me and said, I'm going to close your little bullshit factory. Your office in other words, right? I'm going to close it. And so I took my door off its hinges and put it in front of her door and said, how are you going to close this bullshit factory if it doesn't have any doors?
这位顾问本应监视社交媒体上的学生动态，与他们建立联系，基本上嗅出一切。所以有一天，这位顾问来找我说，我要关闭你的小混蛋工厂。换句话说，就是你的办公室，对吧？我要关闭它。所以我把门从铰链上取下来放在她的门前，说，如果这个混蛋工厂没有门，你要怎么关闭它？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
But, of course, this performance eventually ended, and I returned the door to its place. But in the meantime, she got really committed to this work of telling the students not to come see me.
当然，这场戏最终结束了，我把门放回了原处。但与此同时，她真的致力于这项工作，告诉学生们不要来找我。
And fewer kids were showing up at his office. The domain he'd carved out inside the school-- not just the physical space of his office, but the permission he represented for kids who wanted to joke around, talk freely, ask questions, and for him to be able to do that-- that was being shrunk down to nothing.
而出现在他办公室的孩子越来越少。他在学校里开辟的领域——不仅仅是办公室的物理空间，还有他为那些想开玩笑、自由交谈、提问题的孩子所代表的许可，以及他能够那样做的能力——正在缩减到零。
When I asked Pasha what this period of his life felt like, he gave me an answer that I can't help but classify as literally the most Russian thing I've ever heard. He said it was like this one painting he loves, Barge Haulers on the Volga, which is an oil-on-canvas painting by Ilya Repin. It depicts 11 men hauling a barge along the banks of a river. These men are at the point of collapse from exhaustion, oppressed by heavy, hot weather, leaning into these big leather straps attached to the boat they're pulling. They're exhausted, covered in dirt.
当我问帕夏他人生的这段时期是什么感觉时，他给我的回答我情不自禁地认为是我听过的字面上最俄罗斯的东西。他说这就像他喜爱的一幅画，《伏尔加河上的纤夫》，那是伊利亚·列宾的油画。它描绘了11个人沿着河岸拉着一艘驳船。这些人因为精疲力竭、被沉重炎热的天气压迫，倾身在连接着他们拉的船的巨大的皮带上，处于崩溃的边缘。他们筋疲力尽，浑身是泥。
But among them stands a younger man, whose face is in the path of the sun. He looks in a different direction. He looks up. And his body refuses to pull the boat. He seems to be the only one questioning the work they're being asked to do.
但在他们之中站着一个年轻人，他的脸正对着阳光。他看向不同的方向。他往上看。他的身体拒绝拉船。他似乎是唯一一个质疑他们被要求做的这项工作的人。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
Like, why are we doing all this? And the rest of them just keep their head down, keep pulling this ship along the Volga--
就像，我们为什么要做这一切？而其余的人只是低下头，继续沿着伏尔加河拉这艘船——
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
--as if they don't hear what he's saying.
——好像他们没听到他在说什么。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
It's like you're speaking different languages and you won't understand each other. You don't have points of contact. You don't have common views on basically any questions. You can't discuss issues that demand discussion. They require it, not because you can change something, but because you need to not be alone. You need to speak in order to feel support, to find at least one person that you can talk about this with. But there's no one.
这就像你在说不同的语言，你们不会理解对方。你们没有共同点。你们在基本任何问题上都没有共同观点。你们无法讨论需要讨论的问题。他们需要它，不是因为你可以改变什么，而是因为你需要不孤单。你需要说话才能感觉到支持，找到至少一个你可以谈论这件事的人。但没有一个人。
There is one last scene in the film that really got to me. It's so inside in a way that lets you really feel how much has changed in this one school, this one town. Pasha gets invited to this party of a recent graduate, Vanya, who's heading off to the army. It's his going away party. All his friends toast to him and wish him luck in the future. They pose for pictures with Vanya. Instead of "cheese," they say, "army!"
电影中有一个最后的场景真的打动了我。它是如此的内在，以至于让你真正感受到这所学校、这个城镇发生了多少变化。帕夏受邀参加了一位应届毕业生瓦尼亚的派对，他正要去参军。这是他的告别派对。他所有的朋友为他干杯，祝他未来好运。他们和瓦尼亚拍照。他们不说“茄子”，而是说“军队！”
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
Then they take turns shaving his head with a shaver that breaks halfway through the process.
然后他们轮流用一把在过程中坏掉的剃须刀剃他的头。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
[SHAVER BUZZING]
[剃须刀嗡嗡声]
Pasha takes a turn at shaving Vanya's head. As he does it, he asks, you decided to sign up on your own?
帕夏轮到给瓦尼亚剃头。当他做的时候，他问，你决定自己报名参军？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
Vanya says, didn't have time. They sent for me. Pasha says, why didn't you call me? Vanya sort of shrugs, as if Pasha's question is dumb and annoying. But then, quietly, he mumbles, it just all happened so fast, in a split second. Besides that, it's all laughs and jokes and debauchery. The shaving part is funny. Everyone's kind of wasted.
瓦尼亚说，没时间了。他们送我去了。帕夏说，为什么不打电话给我？瓦尼亚耸了耸肩，好像帕夏的问题很蠢很烦人。但后来，他轻轻地嘟囔说，这一切发生得太快了，就在一瞬间。除此之外，全是欢笑、笑话和颓废。剃头部分很有趣。大家都喝得有点多了。
But then as it gets late, Vanya and his friends start embracing. One guy cries and hugs him, tells him that he really loves him so much, that he won't forget him. He tells him, you're like a brother to me, not by blood, but by soul.
但后来天晚了，瓦尼亚和他的朋友们开始拥抱。一个人哭了，拥抱他，告诉他他真的很爱他，他不会忘记他。他告诉他，你对我来说就像兄弟，不是血缘，而是灵魂。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
Vanya doesn't look so brave in the dark. He looks small and scared. His friends also do. And that's when it hit me. Before now, Vanya and the others seem like they maybe believed in this war, like they wouldn't mind going to fight for Russia. But in this moment, it feels like you can see everyone grasp the realness of the thing they'd been saying, and then immediately understand that there was now no turning back, like a joke gone too far. Because at this point, so many Russians have gone to fight this war, and well over 100,000 Ukrainians have been killed in it.
瓦尼亚在黑暗中看起来没那么勇敢。他看起来又小又怕。他的朋友们也一样。就在那时，我明白了。在此之前，瓦尼亚和其他人似乎可能相信这场战争，好像他们不介意去为俄罗斯战斗。但在那一刻，感觉你可以看到每个人都抓住了他们一直在说的事情的真实性，然后立即明白现在没有回头路了，就像一个开过火的玩笑。因为此时，这么多俄罗斯人已经去打这场战争了，而超过10万乌克兰人在其中丧生。
Do people believe the propaganda? I wondered this question over and over again as I was watching. Does Vanya actually believe in the war he's going to fight? Do the teachers believe that Russia is denazifying Ukraine? Do the kids throwing fake grenades believe in the country they are being trained to defend? It's a version of the question I've been asking my family my whole life. But did you believe in the things you were being taught, the things you were doing, the slogans hung up in the gym? Those are the questions they seem the most frustrated by.
人们相信宣传吗？我在观看时一遍又一遍地问这个问题。瓦尼亚真的相信他要去打的这场战争吗？老师们相信俄罗斯正在对乌克兰进行去纳粹化吗？那些投掷假手榴弹的孩子们相信他们被训练去保卫的国家吗？这是我一生都在问我家人的那个问题的变体。但你们相信你们被教导的事情，你们正在做的事情，挂在健身房里的标语吗？那些似乎是让他们感到最沮丧的问题。
It took me asking Pasha to figure out why. When I asked him if the people around him believe in all this, he scoffed at me, the way my grandma does, like, that's a bad question, you dummy journalist. Don't you understand? He told me, it doesn't matter if people believe in it or not. What matters is that they say it, that they hang the slogans, teach the lessons, sing the anthems.
我问帕夏才弄明白原因。当我问他周围的人是否相信这一切时，他像我祖母那样嘲笑我，就像，这是一个坏问题，你这个笨蛋记者。你不明白吗？他告诉我，人们信不信并不重要。重要的是他们说了，他们挂了标语，教了课程，唱了国歌。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
First, it's a routine that's like, I believe, I don't believe, but I say it.
首先，这是一种常规，就像，我信，我不信，但我说了。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
Then it becomes culture. These lessons are already in the schedule. Everyone's used to it, like, you got to say this. You got to listen to that. You got to raise the flag or whatever else.
然后它变成了文化。这些课程已经在日程表上了。每个人都习惯了，比如，你得说这个。你得听那个。你得升旗或做其他事。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
And then it becomes a cage, and you think this is normal. And I'd also add that the cage actually remains open.
然后它变成了一个笼子，你认为这是正常的。我还要补充一点，笼子实际上保持打开状态。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[说俄语]
And you can leave it at any moment. But as soon as you do, you realize that everyone else is in the cage. You walk out, and you realize that you've become an outcast, a loner, that your opinion, you, yourself, you don't matter to anyone. And that's also the work of propaganda. That's what it does.
你可以随时离开它。但一旦你离开，你就会意识到其他人都在笼子里。你走出去，你意识到你已经成了局外人，一个孤独的人，你的意见，你自己，你对任何人都不重要。这也就是宣传的工作。这就是它所做的。
Pasha became more and more isolated, retreated from his friends and family. They stayed away from him too. An unmarked vehicle showed up outside his home. And he got scared and left the country without telling anyone where he was going or why. And he can't go back.
帕夏变得越来越孤立，退出了他的朋友和家人。他们也远离了他。一辆没有标记的车辆出现在他家门外。他害怕了，没告诉任何人他要去哪或为什么就离开了这个国家。他回不去了。
I should probably fess up now and say, all those times I was asking my family about how they felt, growing up, when I was posing those exact questions to Pasha, in the back of my mind, I was always wondering, who would I be if I was put in that situation, what kind of person? Would I be able to see what was happening and push back?
我现在可能应该坦白说，所有那些我问家人他们成长感受的时候，当我对帕夏提出那些确切的问题时，在我的脑海里，我总是想，如果我处在那样的境地，我会是谁，什么样的人？我能看到发生了什么并反击吗？
When I saw the film and when I talked to Pasha, I found all these similarities between us. We're both similar ages, similar tendency to ask questions. And I did think-- quietly, to myself-- that had I been put in the situation, I probably would be like Pasha. I told my dad this-- big mistake.
当我看到这部电影并与帕夏交谈时，我发现了我们之间的所有相似之处。我们年纪相仿，有类似的提问倾向。我确实想——悄悄对自己说——如果我处在那种境地，我可能会像帕夏一样。我告诉了我爸爸——大错特错。
He said, really? You'd be like that? What are you doing right now in this country? There are things happening here that you don't like. Then I said, I'm doing my best, I think. Then he said, well, isn't that great? Your best. What's that got to do with anything?
他说，真的吗？你会像那样？你现在在这个国家做什么？这里发生了一些你不喜欢的事情。然后我说，我在尽我所能，我想。然后他说，那不是太棒了吗？你的尽力。那跟任何事情有什么关系？
Valerie Kipnis is one of the producers of our show. The actor who's reading Pasha's quotes in English was E. Lia Kleinbock.
瓦莱丽·基普尼斯是我们节目的制作人之一。阅读帕夏英文引语的演员是E.利亚·克莱因博克。
Well, our program was produced today by Nadia Reiman and edited by Nancy Updike. The people who put together today's show include Chana Joffe-Walt, Adriene Lilly, Tobin Low, Molly Marcello, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Ruthie Petitto, Ryan Rumery, Ruby Schwartz, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman, Senior Editor, David Kestenbaum. Our Executive Editor is Emanuele Berry.
嗯，我们的节目今天由娜迪亚·雷曼制作，南希·厄普代克编辑。今天节目组的人员包括查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、阿德里恩·莉莉、托宾·洛、莫莉·马塞洛、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·纳尔逊、鲁西·佩蒂托、瑞安·鲁梅里、鲁比·施瓦茨、弗朗西斯·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、玛丽莎·罗伯逊-泰克斯特、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。我们的主编是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼，高级编辑，大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Special thanks today to Emmanuelle Pare, David Borenstein, Katia Kize, Bela Shayevich, Daniel Plyam, Katherine Emery, Ruth and Mark Fitzpatrick, Henry Frank, Chris Lavoie, and Brett Morse. Elaine Appleton Grant's story in Act One was supported by a grant from the National Institute for Health Care Management. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
今天特别感谢艾曼纽·帕雷、大卫·博伦斯坦、卡蒂亚·基泽、贝拉·沙耶维奇、丹尼尔·普利亚姆、凯瑟琳·埃默里、鲁思和马克·菲茨帕特里克、亨利·弗兰克、克里斯·拉沃伊和布雷特·莫尔斯。伊莱恩·阿普尔顿·格兰特在第一幕的故事得到了国家医疗保健管理研究所的资助。这部《美国生活》由公共广播交易所PRX发送到公共广播电台。
Special thanks today to This American Life Partners Sean Collins and Stonewall and Traveler Peek. Sean Collins, I know you. We worked together at NPR. Nice to see you here in this ad. How's Oklahoma? They and all of our Life Partners have subscribed to help us keep making our program. When you do that, you get to listen ad free. And you get other stuff, including bonus episodes. Our most recent one that I did with one of my coworkers, Diane Wu, turned out so much more emotional and personal than I think either of us expected.
今天特别感谢《美国生活》合作伙伴肖恩·柯林斯和斯通沃尔以及旅行者皮克。肖恩·柯林斯，我认识你。我们在NPR共事过。很高兴在这里看到你的广告。俄克拉荷马怎么样？他们和我们所有的生活伙伴都认购了，以帮助我们继续制作节目。当你这样做时，你可以收听无广告版。你还可以获得其他东西，包括额外剧集。我和我的同事黛安·吴制作的最新一期节目，其感人和个人程度比我们预期的要高得多。
Anyway, if you want to hear that, you got to join. Go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. That link is also in the show notes. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. His dream job was actually to be on Sesame Street. When he auditioned, he was told his performance was not quite right for children.
无论如何，如果你想听，你必须加入。去thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。该链接也在节目说明中。一如既往，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。他的梦想工作其实是出现在《芝麻街》。当他试镜时，他被告知他的表演不太适合儿童。
We're going to count. 1, 2, 3!
我们要数了。1，2，3！
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。